now people have a lot of misconceptions
about science about how it works and
what it is a big one is that science is
just a big ol pile of facts but that's
not true that's not even the goal of
science science is a process it's a way
of thinking gathering facts is just a
piece of it but it's not the goal the
ultimate goal of science is to
understand objective reality the best
way we know how and that's based on
evidence now the problem here is that
people are flawed we can be fooled we're
really good at fooling ourselves and so
baked into this process is a way of
minimizing our own bias so sort of boil
down more than is probably useful here's
how this works if you want to do some
science what you want to do is you want
to observe something say the sky is blue
hey I wonder why you question it the
next thing you do is you come up with an
idea that may explain it a hypothesis
well you know what
oceans are blue maybe the sky is
reflecting the colors from the ocean
great but now you have to test it so you
predict what that might mean your
prediction would be well if the sky is
reflecting the ocean color it'll be
bluer on the coasts than it will be in
the middle of the country okay
that's fair enough but you got to test
that prediction so you get on a plane
you leave Denver on a nice gray day you
fly to LA you look up and the sky is
gloriously blue hooray
your thesis is proven but is it really
know you've made one observation you
need to think about your hypothesis
think about how to test it and do more
than just one maybe you could go to a
different part of the country or a
different part of the year and see what
the weather is like that another good
idea is to talk to other people they
have different ideas different
perspectives and they can help you this
is what we call peer review and in fact
that will probably also save you a lot
of money and a lot of time flying coast
to coast just
check the weather now what happens if
your hypothesis does a decent job but
not a perfect job well that's okay
because what you can do is you can
modify a little bit and then go through
this whole process again make
predictions test them and do that and as
you do that over and over again you will
hone this idea and if it gets good
enough it may be accepted by the
scientific community at least
provisionally as a good explanation of
what's going on
at least until a better idea or some
contradictory evidence comes along now
part of this process is admitting when
you're wrong and that can be really
really hard science has its strengths
and weaknesses and they depend on this
now one of the strengths of science is
that it's done by people and it's proven
itself to do a really good job where we
understand the universe pretty well
because of science one of Sciences
weaknesses is that it's done by people
and we bring a lot of baggage along with
us when we investigate things we are
egotistical we are stubborn we're
superstitious we're tribal we're humans
these are all human traits and
scientists are humans and so we have to
be aware of that when we're studying
science and when we're trying to develop
our theses but part of this whole thing
part of the scientific process part of
the scientific method is admitting when
you're wrong I know I've been there many
years ago I was working on Hubble Space
Telescope and a scientist I worked with
came to me with some data and he said I
think there may be a picture of a planet
orbiting another star in this data we
have not had any pictures taken of a
planets orbiting other stars yet so if
this were true then this would be the
first one and we would be the ones who
found it that's a big deal I was very
excited so I just dug right into this
data I spent a long time trying to
figure out if this thing were planted or
not the problem is planets are faint and
stars are bright so trying to get the
signal out of this data was like trying
to hero
spurinna in a heavy metal concert was
really hard I tried everything I could
but after a month of working on this I
came to a realization couldn't do it I
had to give up and I had to tell this
other scientist the date is too messy we
can't say whether this is a planet or
not and that was hard
then later on we got follow-up
observations with Hubble and it showed
that it wasn't a planet it was a
background star a galaxies something
like that well let's get too technical
but that sucked I was really unhappy
about this but that's part of it you
have to it you have to say look you know
we can't do this with the data we have
and then I had to face up to the fact
that even the follow-up data showed we
were wrong emotionally I was pretty
unhappy but if a scientist is doing
their job correctly being wrong is not
so bad because that means there's still
more stuff out there more things to
figure out scientists don't love being
wrong but we love puzzles and the
universe is the biggest puzzle of them
all now having said that if you have a
piece and it doesn't fit no matter how
you move it jamming it in harder isn't
gonna help there gonna be a time where
you have to let go of your idea if you
want to understand the bigger picture
the price of doing science is admitting
when you're wrong but the payoff is the
best there is knowledge and
understanding and I can give you a
thousand examples of this in science but
there's one I really like has to do with
astronomy and it was a question that had
been plaguing astronomers literally for
centuries when you look at the Sun it
seems special it is the brightest object
in the sky but having studied astronomy
physics chemistry thermodynamics for
centuries we learn something very
important about it it's not that special
it's a star just like millions of other
stars but that raises an interesting
question if the Sun is a star and the
Sun has planets do these other stars
have planets well like I said with my
own failure and the planet I was looking
for finding them is super
but scientists tend to be pretty clever
people and they used a lot of different
techniques and started observing stars
and over the decades they started
finding some things that were pretty
interesting hairy edge of what they were
able to detect but time and again it was
shown to be wrong that all changed in
1991 couple of astronomers alexander lin
and rule in pardon me and matthew bales
had a huge announcement they had found a
planet orbiting another star and not
just any star but a pulsar and this is
the remnant of a star that has
previously exploded is blasting out
radiation this is the last place in the
universe you would expect to find a
planet but they had very methodically
looked at this pulsar and they've
detected the gravitational tug of this
planet as it orbited the Pulsar it
looked really good the first planet
orbiting another star had been found
except not so much after they made the
announcement a bunch of other
astronomers commented on it and so they
went back and looked at their data and
realized they had made a very
embarrassing mistake they had not
accounted for some very subtle
characteristics of the Earth's motion
around the Sun which affected how they
measured this planet going around the
Pulsar and it turns out that when they
did account for it correctly poof their
planet disappeared what in real so
Andrew Lyne had a very formidable task
he had to admit this so in 1992 at the
American Astronomical Society meeting
which is one of the largest gatherings
of astronomers on the planet he stood up
and announced that he had made a mistake
and that the planet did not exist and
what happens next
oh I love this what happened next was
wonderful he got an ovation the
astronomers weren't angry at him didn't
want to chastise him they praised him
for his honesty and his integrity I love
that scientists are people and it gets
better
Lyne steps off the podium the next guy
to come up is a man named Alexander
volscian he takes the microphone and
says yeah so Lin's team didn't find a
pulse our planet but my team found not
just one but two planets orbiting at
different pulsar we knew about the
problem that Lyn had we checked for it
and yeah ours are real and it turns out
he was right and in fact a few months
later they found a third planet orbiting
this pulsar and it was the first
exoplanet system ever found what we call
alien worlds exoplanets that to me is is
just wonderful at that point the
floodgates were opened in 1995 a planet
was found around a star more like the
Sun and then we found another and
another this is an image of an actual
planet orbiting an actual star we kept
getting better at it we started finding
him by the bucketload we started finding
thousands of them we built Observatory
specifically designed to look for them
and now we know a thousands of them we
even know of planetary systems that is
actual data animated showing four
planets orbiting another star this is
incredible think about that for all of
human history you could count all the
known planets in the universe on two
hands nine eight nine eight eight
huh but now we know they're everywhere
every star for every star you've seen
the sky there could be three five ten
planets the sky is filled with them we
think that planets may outnumber stars
in the galaxy this is a profound
statement and it was made because of
science and it wasn't made just because
of science and the observatories in the
data it was made because of the
scientists who built the observatories
who took the data who made the mistakes
and admit admitted them and then let
other science scientists build on their
mistakes so that they could do what they
do and figure out where are places in
the universe that is how you find the
truth science is at its best when it
dares to be human thank you
[Applause]